ah confusing look hi guys my name is
Kurt W don't know now you know you're
like it's different now I went on my
Twitter and asked you guys what kind of
video to join us see today and someone
said rocky handles the morning after a
Valentine's Day one-night stand and
that's a completely valid thing to want
to know how to handle so if you're
watching this video right now I'm sure
you've already handled it if you are
still at or dealing with a one-night
stand and you're watching this video
weird but also I hope this is helpful
I've made videos like this in the past
in which I think the answers to a lot of
life's difficult questions can be found
in music so here are three different
ways that you can handle a Valentine's
Day one-night stand it's the one I stand
is at your house okay here's how they
use music to check out a one-night stand
my first method is to use pure raw
unadulterated honesty it is direct and
it's no [ __ ] your child could go
down good morning beautiful okay I won't
lie to you I have no idea who you are
the sign of Siva I do know that you know
whoa oh no like you care they do with a
smell like what let's called your list
steve is here he's driving a Honda Civic
okay yes cool that's cool
we make help there's no stopping where
are your Capricorn no like I said
there's no stopping the second method
it's be really passive-aggressive by way
of pretending that you're crazy here no
that could go down come on beautiful
it looks going see better - - what
[ __ ] Rick Cooper what friends the
friends inside my head okay okay
we hope there's no stopping and the
third method just pretending you've
lockjaw
good morning beautiful I'm gonna go but
did you see magic it's bad no stop
saying oh there is some oven methods for
handling the morning-after not only a
Valentine's Day one-night stand but you
know any one-night stand you might have
I hope these are really helpful how was
your Valentine's Day cool ray awesome if
you liked this video give it a thumbs up
and click this button to subscribe to
this YouTube channel cuz you know we put
thought into things sometimes like this
outfit I don't know